I went to tech school I went to MIT and
it was great I fit in
you know we could all talk math to each
other lots of fun and then I got done
with college and I realized I had
learned a lot of stuff but I hadn't
actually learned any social skills and
so maybe some of you can kind of relate
to this a little bit and so I I started
thinking that maybe you know I'm not so
good at talking to people I'm but I'm
not bad at building electronics or
writing code so maybe there's a way that
I can kind of hack my way out of the
situation and so the first thing I
started to try to make was this one
it won't break the skin but it's not
pleasant that's better okay cool um yeah
so this was a series there's also the
anti Day dreaming device that would detect
if I was talking to someone and vibrate
vigorously or on the neck to keep me
paying attention and there's a body
contact training seat because I felt
like I was bad at this kind of casual
body contact thing so it would detect if
I was touching someone and if I went too
long without making any body contact or
it would start to fade this white noise into
the hood of it and so that in order to
talk to someone I had to touch them
every once in a while and so all of
these were kind of asking this question
of you you know I was thinking like how
can I kind of fit in better but then
also what what are these expectations
and why is it necessary for me to do
this um so alone the same time I was
reading a lot of Erving Goffman who's a
sociologist in the who wrote a lot in
the 60s and 70s
look thinking about this idea of social
interaction kind of as dramatic
performance in this idea that we all
have these kind of roles that we play
and when we meet people we try to
discern this role so we might meet
someone new would say oh you know he's a
doctor like my dad Bruce and he's a
really funny like my friend David and he
lives in Michigan like my friend Aaron
and then as you get to know the person
you say oh okay he's not an anything
like Bruce or David or Aaron he's
actually this you know unique person and
you kind of chisel away this unique
portrait of someone and so these will
roles are really useful because if you
know you went into every conversation
without any kind of assumption or
expectation it would take forever right
you wouldn't know if you should speak
English you wouldn't know if you should
say hello or shake their hand or you
wouldn't know what to start talking
about so we make certain assumptions and
this helps us but my
at what point do these assumptions we
make start to kind of reflect back onto
the person we're interacting with and
kind of start to you know shape them the
way that they are rather than letting
them be they're kind of unique selves so
those are thinking a lot about this
question of you know and what sort of
responsibilities do we have to maintain
a consistent pattern of identity to
uphold the role that people think that
you are or an understandable pattern and
behaviors and when we break that what
happens and so I was thinking a lot
about the kind of feedback that we give
to each other and so I made this table
and the idea was that you could rate
during the conversation how much you're
enjoying it by moving this foot pedal
from positive negative and the tabletop
would aggregate all the responses to
show kind of anonymously you know
whether you're interesting or not and
then if it got too low it would start
flashing a distress signal for someone
to come in and save the conversation so
I was interesting yeah so we've all
wanted that right so it was interesting
when I showed this to people they were
kind of upset and they said you know
like I wouldn't want that in my living
room that would make me totally
uncomfortable because I I want you know
I don't want feedback while I'm talking
to people I'm just gonna reserve all
that feedback for liking by tweets and
fading things so a lot of this work is
inspired by this kind of critical design
work that was sort of pioneered by
Anthony Dunne and Fiona Raby who just
recently retired from the Royal College
of Art so these are two projects this
first one is called placebo project and
basically what they did is they made
these home objects that kind of
referenced different ways to relate to
electromagnetic fields in the home and
they none of the objects really did
anything someone who moved a little bit
but what they did was they took them and
they gave them to people and let them
live with them for a extended period of
time and then they interviewed them at
the end and what they found was that
even though the people knew that they
didn't really work they all started to
develop their
relationships with these objects they
started to make rituals around them they
started to feel more comfortable and
they could interact with them in certain
ways and so this was a really kind of
powerful idea for me that you know we
can that a technology does it can just
be there and it can be kind of a vessel
for us to add ourselves to and then and
do you want to replace the existing
normal this was the this was a sexual
obsessive compulsive disorder machine so
the idea is that if you're someone that
was kind of addicted to porn you'd watch
this screen and hold onto this rod and
then as you got more aroused the video
would get more pixelated and so in order
to watch the video you'd have to keep
yourself calm so you could kind of
retrain your your addiction or your urge
there were known torrents accessories
for lonely men so these are a chest hair
twirler heavy breather a plate thrower a
sheet stealer cold feet or a hair
smotherer for bed or thinking about
Sputniko's menstruation machine device
that would apply pressure and pain to
the abdomen and then release
blood on the inside of the leg to give
men the experience of having a period or
Christoph Moo disco supporter purl this
is a older piece where he was working
with people that felt like they had
stories to tell that they couldn't
didn't necessarily feel comfortable or
able or empowered empowered to tell and
so he would record the story and they
would wear it using this mouthpiece that
was kind of served simultaneously as a
mouthpiece but also resembled something
like a gag
to communicate this story and the ones
that I'm really excited about are
projects like these things that actually
work in some way so for another example
Kelly Dobson scream body a device you
know for those situations where you feel
like you just need to scream
you could scream into this device and it
could be carefully captured without bothering anyone
around you and then when you're in a
more appropriate environment you could
release it so I guess these are all kind
of addressing you know how do we deal
with this perpetual performance of self
and what happens when we feel like we
don't quite fit into it or how do we
decide what to perform well it's really
interested you know I've been doing all
these pieces about kind of feedback
either through an algorithm or for
others and I thought what if rather than
feedback I could just get a direct kind
of content so this was a a one-month
piece where my life was collaboratively
scripted by everyone on the internet and
so basically every day I'd post a script
for the following day and it would be
blank at the start and then people could
log on to this site and edit it wiki
style they could write in directions
they could write themselves and they
could add costumes or lines scenery and
then at midnight it would close and that
would become my script for the following
day and I had to perform all the lines
and actions in the script so this was
kind of a continuous thing that would
last for a month and it was interesting
because when I started you know the
first few weeks of it it felt really
constricting I felt like I was kind of
controlled at every moment and I was
trapped in this art piece but there
became this moment sort of halfway
through where it suddenly felt kind of
freeing and I realized that you know all
these things that I was being forced to
do felt really uncomfortable because I
thought you know that's not me and I
realize how narrow of a box like me I
had decided me really was and the thing
that I discovered through doing this
project is that I could say something
kind of on a typical of me or I could do
something different and the sky wouldn't
fall down and my my friends would still
be my friends and so this was kind of a
moment where I realized there's so much
more out there you know if we stop
holding on so tightly to the kind of
patterns that we have where the
expectations we have for ourselves
and so another really big source of
influence for me is thinking about
performance art and so this is a
one-year performance by Tehching Hsieh
and Linda Montano where they were just
connected by a rope for a year and they
couldn't touch each other but they had
to maintain this connection more I think
of VALIE EXPORT tapp und tast kino you know or tap and touch cinema where she's
walking around the streets with this
kind of like box in front of her with
curtains and then inviting people to
stick their hands through and feel her
bare chest underneath and I just I see
this this image is really powerful for
me I think the the the look between
these two people and then also the
look on that creepy guy in the
background you know I think I think a
lot about kind of interaction design and
sometimes we get so kind of carried away
with like we need more buttons or we
need more design or we need something
fancier but these two pieces for me
really show that like a simple
intervention done well can really kind
of transform the way that we are
relationship to other people are true
our experience or speaking of interfaces
Marina Abramovic is rhythm zero where
she was on a table with this series of
objects and people could use them in any
way they wanted against her or on her
and it really got quite out of control
and the thing that sticks out for me
about this one is you know this piece
was years ago but just by being in the
room every single person was implicated
right so even if they chose not to do
anything that was still a choice and I
think this becomes even more relevant
when we think about the Internet today
you know if you see something happening
online or you see something in your
everyday life you know walking by and
deciding not to do anything or just
sitting back and watching it that's a
choice just as much as acting is or
calling card Adrian Piper so you know
this idea like directly confronting
someone with you know we have all these
kind of expectations are these unspoken
rules about how we interact but what if
you just tell someone exactly
how you want to be interacted with how
you want to be spoken to and I'm interested in these kind of like larger systems
that we can intervene within for example
Jill Magid did Evidence Locker where she was
walking around the streets in England
captured by the very pervasive CCTV
system wearing this red jacket and the
she was able to obtain all the logs and
the video clips of her walking by
submitting requests to the city for
these these logs and documents and so in
order to do that she had to fill out
this form requesting the footage but she
filled it out in a way as if she were
speaking to a lover or she was kind of
creating this relationship with a larger
system and negotiating it on her terms
so I was interested in this idea of like
kind of interacting with the system and
changing it in some way I also was
trying to find a way to take that kind
of freeing feeling I felt by you know
having these different sorts of
interactions than I normally do like in
the script piece and how could I let
other people have that feeling as well
so I made this app a few years ago
called interact
so this was a few years ago and the the
question here was you know can we create
some sort of invisible system or layer
on top of normal reality in order to
kind of find the space that we need to
to interact in the ways that we want to
or could an app rather than reinforcing
the patterns of behavior that we have
challenged us to define new ones or to
interact in different ways and so you
know this piece I did this in 2011 and I
think this was kind of like a something
I hadn't seen before but I feel really
excited because I think since then this
is kind of like old news you know
there's all sorts of like Foursquare
things now where you can post what you
want to be doing and people can come and
join you or is it this are there's apps
like cuddler so you can find someone
that if you just want to cuddle and you
know this is just one example but
basically for every possible interaction
you could imagine there's probably an
app for that or maybe you want to
deliver a message to someone but you
can't just you just can't tell them
yourself so there's Miranda July
Somebody app yeah
it's me Jessica I so totally love you I
just I can't and this I can't be your girlfriend anymore
it's not anything you did you're perfect
I just need some space
you gonna be all right man you got this
Or Scott Garner's hell as other people
so he's using the FourSquare API here to
find a path for you from where you are
to where you want to be while avoiding
all of your friends and contacts so I'm
really excited that's great I use it a
lot so I'm really excited about this
that there are these kind of like new
apps in this new sort of experimental
space coming I think and it can kind of
push back against some of these pet apps
that really reinforce our patterns so I
was thinking more about the the crowds
crowdsourcing the the idea of
crowdsourcing and I was thinking okay
that worked kind of all right for my my
life in general maybe I could apply it
to my dating life specifically where I
could really it's not see it doesn't
seem to be working with with just me so
I did this piece Social Turkers
found it
so I actually go into every one of these
pieces performance pieces with this idea
that like if it worked you know I don't
usually have an end date I have maybe a
period of time that I would like it to
last at least but then I think you know
if it just worked I might keep going
forever in this way needless to say this
one ended after a month but some of the
questions I was thinking about is just
you know could this like hive mind or
this networked intelligence actually be
smarter than just me on on my own why
are we always feeling like we have to go
through our relationships and figure
them all out on our own when there is so
much collective wisdom among the world
everyone's gone through these sorts of
things or maybe you know as myself here
in the situation I am so kind of in the
middle of it that I can't even see
objectively what's happening
you know there's the suggestion from one
of the workers like he's into you and
maybe I just have not seen it so could
some third party observer be a better
better judge of what's happening and is
this still me you know it as I'm
following the instructions of people
that are coming to my phone is this this
okay is this if I've decided that I'm
going to use this system to augment my
life then I I felt at the time at least
that that was my decision whatever came
out of it
and so I took this you know when I was
doing this piece it was kind of
complicated because it's very hacked
together and it's kind of like got
actually had two devices one was like in
my phone filming and one was like you
know maybe scene text messages and
sometimes because I was constantly
tweaking the system sometimes it would
crash and I'd have to run to the
bathroom and like SSH in and fix it and
come back on me like yes I just put on
some lipstick and so I was thinking well
what if we could I could make an app
like this that like anyone could use in
any situation so I teamed up with this
design studio in the Netherlands some
friends their studio is called preceptor
and we made an app called crowd pilot
and the ideas that wasn't just her dates
as for any situation in addition to
hiring Mechanical Turk workers you could
also invite Facebook friends either all
of them or specific ones or there was
like a public page where you could
request volunteers to assist and it
would just go up on this page and anyone
could kind of drop into your session so
maybe it's sounding a bit like your cat
or periscope at this point this is a few
years ago and so you could give you a
crowd of pilots kind of a brief about
you know what you're what you needed
help with or what the situation was and
they could send you suggestions and you
could there was a mechanism for saying
that was a good one or blocking them if
they were giving really unhelpful
suggestions and then this was the public
listening page where you could kind of
choose different sessions that you
wanted to drop into and this is the page
if you dropped in online in you're
listening the interface
and so we you know we really pushed to
make this like a real app you know it
wasn't that was sort of the difference
between the performance and this and so
you know we filmed this this trailer and
I'll play this I guess
Sudheer go ahead
no you go
well the last time you really wished for
something oh you know what I always kind
of wanted to go to all 50 state capitals
yeah how many have you gone to 25 26th I want to go to Carson City
next month and then Olympia Salem
Sacramento Crowd Pilot is an app that lets you
crowdsource your conversations bring
along your friends or invite strangers
to help you in any situation like a date
a meeting a family gathering or just let
them figure out what's going on your
crowd pilots listen in and give you live
suggestions of what to do or say
relax take control take a chance get
crowd pilot yeah so the response was was
was fantastically upset people are a little
creeped out by this there was also the
kind of convenient timing of the whole
NSA thing and so this was the connection
that the media made immediately even
though we're very explicit you know this
is not meant to be a discreet app this
is meant to kind of imagine a future
where we all just you know do this and
are okay with it it's not a big deal and
so people are kind of freaking out I
guess they're petitioning Obama about
something I think Obama was busy though
so it didn't really go anywhere they're
trying to figure out is this an art
project is it an app saying it looks
like it seems like it's a it should be
an art project but looks too slick it
must be a startup I don't know and
they're kind of like digging through
trying to understand then Fox News had
their take on it well if you can't beat
them join them
thanks to the new phone app crowd pilot
the NSA is no longer the only snooping
game in town now you are too tech guru
Cassie slant on how it all works what
are we talking about here well I wish I
had this app back in my dating days it's
weird it's just nerve everywhere this is
actually tempting the evil right there
no but this is actually a great idea
because what it's doing is it's making
another form of what we're already using
social media and it's Besant wait a
minute so yeah there you go fox news's
in favor I think or you know maybe we
should just ban startups and ban ideas
completely but all that the other thing
that I noticed is that a lot of people
were very upset about on Twitter but if
you when I went through it it was
actually like probably 90% of the people
if not more were men and the same time I
would see these lone tweets from women
you know as a socially anxious person
crowd piler doesn't sound as terrible as
you're all making it out to be all right
got this email
okay thanks Laura and I'll give it a try
it's a really great idea I hope you're
successful don't
pay attention to the stupid mail written
tech reviews I'm 34 and single in New
York City and think it's filling a
needed void so there's that but more
importantly people were using it and
that was the reason for making the app
and that was the thing that really
excited me and so I dropped into a few
sessions a couple of these ones and they
were actually you know it's hard to say
how much was there just testing yep but
some of these sounded like legitimate
conversations that were happening and so
to launch the app we teamed up with
rhizome at the new Museum in New York
and we had a Valentine's Day blind date
and so we sent a couple out on the date
and they each use the app and we
streamed it through the rhizome web page
where like anyone on the internet could
kind of join these sessions and help out
and so one of the people on the date was
actually one of my friends and so he
made some drawings and wrote some words
that described a little bit about his
experience so I just wanted to share a
little bit of that so he said we are
talking about we're talking fast about
different topics my app is running well
and I get some good feedback we talk
about code and painting it feels like
this might almost work out this was him
getting instructions on which flour to
bring her ahead of time after we
finished our second drink I feel pretty
comfortable with her but our
conversation does feel a bit hyper
stimulated there's not much time between
our conversation there's no space for
natural pause it is easy to confuse
stimulation with excitement
she turns off her app and we ask for the
check there are a few moments of strange
silence but finally a genuine sense of
presence between two strangers the
withdrawal from crowd pilot is really
disorienting I know they're at least a
few hundred people listening but I am
already feeling displaced from my date
who was physically close so fast and so
easily our presence disappears from one
another I was right
Troi and so I think this illustration
really kind of gets at something that I
feel a lot so I've made it my one of my
official conclusions here
interacting with people can be hard and
technology can make it even more
confusing
that's nothing too profound but it is a
trend that I'm seeing so this is an app
by paying Lin a design for an app called
guiltless excuses the idea is that it
can help you manage or help you create
and manage the excuses that you've used
to avoid people so that you don't use
the same one too often with the same
person or you don't run into them while
you're supposed to be sick and then my
favorite feature is that if you're
feeling really guilty it would allow you
to anonymously donate some money into
that person's bank account to kind of
offset your guilts a little bit or this
is a startup called Eterna me and the
idea is that it stores your you give it
all your kind of chats and emails and
then after you die your family can
continue chatting with an avatar of
yourself and so Google's kind of getting
on this also they have this thing
digital afterlife with in an inactive
account manager so the idea is that like
after you die you can designate someone
to receive all of your Gmail and all of
your documents and all of your personal
data because who wouldn't want you know
your friend or significant other to get
all of that and yeah I'll just leave it
there and so I've been kind of thinking
about ways to interact with these
systems and so another example as I was
wondering if you know github could be
used for you know why don't we have
version control for relationships you
know because there are times you just
say that thing and you want to just
revert to the previous commit before you
screwed it all up so what if we could do
that so this is actually the way that my
my relationship began with my current
boyfriend we were just kind of I
mentioned this idea to him saying like
do you know anyone that's done this why
not it seems so obvious and so he was
saying you know it's kind of an
interesting idea and we were just
chatting and so I put
this repository and kind of tried to
goad goad him or someone on and said you
know here's the idea fork fork me and we
can see what happens and so happened and
this was the beginning of our
relationship and that was actually
turned out what to be way easier than
the whole dating you know crowds first
thing should just cut to the chase so
you know he made the first issue and
then he issued a pull request to fix it
taking out the line that it was open for
forking and we asked ourselves questions
like this and so it's it's been this
process of trying to understand for that
were comfortable with software
developers and how use them use the
structure of them to deal with something
that we're not so good at we're not so
comfortable with and so there's all
these ideas like maybe we could make an
experimental branch and then try
something all different if it doesn't
work you know we just ditch it and if it
if it does work then we could kind of
merge it into the master or maybe if we
got enough people doing this we could
actually like cherry-pick the things
that we're working and kind of patch our
relationship so that's an ongoing
experiment another thing I've been
really interested in is this whole kind
of analytics and the the ways that
computers can understand us and how they
might be able to shape our relationships
for us and so it's together with Kyle my
boyfriend from this from github we we
made this project called us plus so this
is a Google hangout app that you can
download thanked Larry yet I'm doing
okay right now I'm just kind of annoyed
because there's this girl named Stacey
in my yoga class who just got pregnant
and she won't stop talking about it and
I just feel like she's being technology
has made us more connected than ever
shouldn't it help us get more from each
other she just won't stop talking about
her pregnancy and what yoga moves that
the whole class should not do because
she us plus give suggestions based on
speech analysis
and facial expression which is
everything everything is how are you
doing mom well actually things haven't
been all that great I wasn't sure
whether to tell you this but more
honesty more balanced very communicating
and sometimes it's just it's just not
the same I try to talk to you and you
don't respond and I can't even I love
you it's been so long since you said in
had more connection it's looking pretty
bleak and our profit margins fell last
quarter but I think we can turn things
around if we outsource step four we
should be okay we could also get it down
five cents more if we use cheaper
materials in steps 19 and 23 and the
public will never know I like how you
think more productivity more success get
more out of your conversations us+ yeah
so I mean the the question there is it
maybe it seems creepy or weird but what
if it what if it works and is that all
right and so along some Alliance Johanna
has been thinking about this idea of
kind of emotional labor and how much
were sort of expected to be nice or to
pad a certain conversation especially as
a woman and so she made this Bowser
extension that basically would so I
guess I don't have the other of you here
Oh perhaps it's not showing it oh there
we go yeah okay so it would it's
basically a browser extension you can
download and the ideas that you write
your email and your normal you know just
get the facts out there and then it will
add all the niceties but you so you
don't have to do them yourself and so
this was kind of an art project but then
just recently I saw this crystal nose
which is a startup along the similar
lines so it will tell you you know on a
person specific basis you know this
person needs to be directly addressed
you want to get maximal response out of
him
etc and you know so there's a whole lot
of this kind of algorithmic analysis
happening it this was kind of a funny
you know Facebook experiment for me
because I was actually using the same
analysis that we were using in the US
Plus hangout app so I was using the same
linguistic inquiry word-count and so
they were using it to manipulate the the
mood your your mood as you looked at
your Facebook feed and so since the
Fuhrer was erupting I had to respond and
so I made this mood manipulator and I
said why should Zuckerberg get to decide
how you feel
take back control give that control to
an algorithm so so I'm not sure people
really caught the tongue-in-cheek part
of it they were you know I sell a lot of
write-ups like yes here we are like
freeing the data and you're in control
now um and that was one question like
really are you more in control this
you're still using the same algorithm
but the other question was so what would
you do with it interface to your
emotions is it okay to mute your friends
depressing feelings when you just need
to have a good day
is there wrong to want to be happy and
use technology to to help you with that
so you can see the results you know or
Twitter could predict if they could
predict when when your relationship is
going to end and give you kind of an
early warning so you could stock up an
ice cream
would you would you want to know and so
this was the the main question or one of
the main questions I had going into this
last project I'll show and this was
another collaboration with Kyle McDonald
and so we were thinking also a lot about
this kind of quantified self wearable
trend and wondering what if we took that
and applied that to our our social
relationships rather than just tracking
our steps or our cigarettes we only have
so much emotional bandwidth bring it and
limited time our social circles are
widening all those relationships can be
overwhelming now there's an app people
keeper tracks your physical and
emotional response while you're hanging
out and it analyzes the data to identify
who stresses you out and makes you
excited SAP or happy see how your
relationships stack up and let people
keeper find the ones that work for you
it'll automatically manage your
relationships so you don't have to
scheduling time with people that make
you feel good and blocking the ones that
don't forget fake friends failed romance
and FOMO optimize your social life with
people keeper
so yeah just like I said the idea is
that it would pair with this wearable /
sensor remote pretty much any
off-the-shelf device I would send
real-time data over Bluetooth and based
on that heart rate analysis we're
looking for times when you might be
feeling some strong emotion either
stressed or angry or aroused and so
there was a mechanism to report this and
then it would give you this rating so
you could see you know who's making you
feel what and we were trying to see you
know what what would it be to write the
code behind this you know what would
what's the reaction or what's the if
statement if if you're feeling aroused
or if you're feeling calm
and so of course you know it's partially
a critique of this kind of quantified
self thing and we were hoping it was
extreme enough that like maybe you don't
want your your app deleting your friends
for you or um maybe you should be able
to figure out for yourself who who
stresses you out or not
so there's definitely the kind of
critical aspect there but at the same
time there's also an optimistic aspect
and I think this is something I'm always
trying to do is like kind of straddle
both of these at the same time so one
thing that inspired me in particular was
some research at MIT a few years ago
where they were making a wearable vast
for women that were victims of domestic
violence and the best was supposed to
record you know physical violence
against the body and with an idea that
perhaps this could be used as evidence
in court or something but what they
found was that you know even more
significant than holding up his evidence
was it was useful for convincing the the
woman involved or their man that it was
actually happening that it was actually
going on and that might seem strange but
the the situation is that when you're in
the middle of it you you contented like
not see it or you can tend to explain it
away even though your friends might be
seeing it everyone might be telling you
something about the hard data was useful
for saying okay this is real and so I
was thinking what would be the emotional
analog of that what do you do for you
know emotional violence or emotional
abuse could I have some data so that
when my friends are saying get out of
that relationship my app could just say
yeah he's deleted he's done and so we
made the app but the thing that I'm
really excited about also is like
actually trying it and so we did a
residency at CMU where we worked with a
group of undergrads and for one week
they all use the app and they were using
a special version that would actually
manipulate their Facebook wall and post
on other people as well as and message
them and stuff so working through
Facebook so
they're very open-minded and I just
wanted to share some of their kind of
reactions to this experiment
my name is Miles Payton and I'm a
student and teenager I'm hoping it'll be
informative more than anything gonna
kind of remind me like hey you should
pay attention to how you're feeling
around this person using the app as a
justification for not wanting to spend
time with someone there's a lot more
definitive than like just saying like
I'm uncomfortable
very informative and sort of what I was
doing and how my interactions with
people were either negatively or
positively affecting my day
well like the process of going on
Facebook and then like finding or like
stalking someone on Facebook and I'm
like suddenly singing like a post that
you didn't expect to be there by
yourself it's sort of funny because it's
you know challenging your like
authorship like agency in that situation
well made me angry is the most the thing
that stood out the most I think like oh
maybe I shouldn't hang out with mark
maybe he's kind of a dick out and so
we've done this in a few other places we
went to Dublin and we did a similar kind
of trial and and with this one we had
sort of a guidebook or a workbook for
going through the experience so in
addition to just using me app there are
these kind of series of exercises for
causing them to reflect even further on
their relationships and interactions I
really like these pages it says things
to say things not to say oh there's one
more anyway things not to say oh and
this was the key right that was so we
had this page there this section reflect
and I think you know I like building
these apps but the reason that I make
them it goes beyond just a video or just
a design proposal or a website is
because I like this moment when you're
forced to decide how whether and how you
might use them so it's one thing to be
freaked out about crowd pilot or people
keeper or so think that it's great or
the mood manipulator but you have the
you know you get to decide will I
download this thing and why how will I
use it and how it what will happen and
you gets experience that yourself
and and I guess the the main question
for me is like how do we exist within
these frameworks around us you know how
can we find how can we fit them how can
we separate them how can we appropriate
them for our own you know to allow
ourselves have the freedom to to
interact in our own terms and you know I
don't think there are these black or
white like no I don't like Google glass
yes I like this like it's it's a gray
area and I think as much as we can
engage with them with these gray areas
and actually understand the nuance
that's the key towards kind of making
technologies that we actually want and
then building the world that we actually
want to see and so it's kind of fun as
an artist because I think you have the
liberty to go a little bit further and
to like try out these things that other
people might not try and then kind of
report back and so I think that it's
important you know to be a part of the
conversation in that way yeah thanks
questions especially feedback
crowdsourcing kind of projects where
people are either giving you advice or a
project or you've had people tell you
what to do each day was their concern
about like what people would do or you
know like where there's some things you
were like no I'm not gonna do it or like
a user that was like out there control
you or something or you know like where
was that not at all I mean part of it
was testing the limits to see how far I
would go so for example the script
project or the the social Turkish the
dating project I kind of said I will try
you know my intention is to do
everything that I'm instructed to do but
if there was something where I felt like
I couldn't for some reason then I
wouldn't and then that would help me
understand what what those lines were
whether they were ethical or just
comfort or something else another thing
I found and you kind of saw this with
iteration with the social tickers is
that at first I'd just have like every
single thing like sent to me and I was
kind of like this total spaz although
some some of my dates seem to like that
and so I couldn't narrow down to this
approach where instead of everything
coming through someone would suggest
something you know it's kind of like a
reddit style or something you like
upvote it and if it got a certain number
of votes then then it would come to me
and so that kind of also helped weed out
some of the kind of random stuff I think
my a few stalkers are discouraged and
the other half of it is building these
apps which in some sense allow other
people to do art exploration yeah and so
I'm curious how you see other people use
for example car fire
yeah do they see the same things that
you wish to see or did you see something
I think everyone has their own
experience which is a little bit of what
I was trying to communicate by Shang
soft hands story it's also sometimes
they're used in really really unexpected
way so a friend of mine from India told
me that some of his friends there had
gotten seen the app and they were using
it when they would go on kind of the
predate before an arranged marriage
because they felt like they would go on
the state and they would be so kind of
caught up and trying to impress the guy
and a good impression but also I
understand that they liked him that
they'd get to the end and not even know
what to think
or not have asked him the questions they
wanted to so they were actually using it
on this state and their friend would say
ask him this or at the end they would
say no don't you know tell him no or
you're leaving or whatever or say this
thing and so I think one married was
actually like prevented because of this
another marriage was successfully
endorsed so I mean that's another part
to that I would like to understand
better is a lot of this work is
obviously very you know American centric
and I think it would be vastly different
very differently understood and
different cultures and countries and so
just showing it in a few different
countries the responses are always
really different in in really good ways
I think we showed people keeper in
Dublin we did this one-week experiment
and the thing with it is that it one of
the things it does is it creates these
text messages for you let's say like you
know you're stressing me out or whatever
and the people in Dublin were saying
like we would never send something that
confrontational like this doesn't so
that was kind of like another
interesting moment yeah like a
particular it reminded me of some of the
other crowdsourcing projects out there
was wrote less
thank you mean centric
twitchplayspokemon and stuff so do you
think that there's room for projects
like that better crowdfunding but
you know don't actually have an impact
on people's lives to actually influence
the development of this and where do you
see kind of that influence going what
path you kind of see this going campus
yeah I think those projects are really
interesting and I look at them a lot and
a lot of times what I'm doing is trying
to take something that doesn't already
address the social and see what happens
like for example this quantified self
thing I mean yeah it's reflecting our
lives but I hadn't seen a lot that it
was just beginning to look at like our
relationships with other people for
example like spreadsheets you can
quantify your sex life so yeah I think
these projects are really interesting
and sometimes you there are things you
can't experiment so easily with in terms
of like relationships that you can with
Pokemon or something and so that that's
a point where it's especially useful to
like see these different mechanisms and
then think about how they might be
applied a personal story of how you were
sort of like using technology to learn
social skills and I sort of so now that
I've seen all the cool stuff you did I
definitely see that theme and I kind of
want to know your stance on that sort of
way light like you recommend it to other
people like it seems like they get repo
maybe had the most effect just judging
um so yeah what's your stance on that
now um have you been better yeah well I
mean I think I'll every time I start a
project I try to figure out the thing
that would like terrify that me the most
and so at the beginning that was just
like smiling we were touching someone
we're talking to them and then it kind
of moved into dating someone or being in
a relationship and so I think what's
really helpful for me is by kind of
making a little art project out of it
it helps me take this thing that feels
like all around me and all encompassing
and turn it into something that is like
oh this is a piece of work and I can
look at it from these different angles
and I can step away from it and then
when I feel kind of done with it I can
set it aside and move on to the next
thing so I don't know if anyone would
say I'm like
master of the social graces at this
moment in my life but it it's definitely
been a useful process for kind of like
moving understanding myself to I walked
in sort of late so I might have missed
it but if you had to describe like or
put a label on these kinds of apps and
experiments or pieces that um like what
what kind of work is it or what do you
call it like what would what are these
apps like what label they fall under
like what would you convey to somebody
like you want to do it like get on like
if you wanted to best convey but these
apps report and the idea behind them and
really are social context oh really well
is different of every audience because
people are different ways relating to it
oh one question I get a lot is like is
this an app or is it an art project or
is it a research project and it's kind
of both or you know I would say yes it's
an app and it's an art project I don't
think it has to be one or the other and
I think more generally I guess I'm
trying to kind of understand the way
that we build relationships relate to
other people like create our own
identities through using art and
technology and something kind of
critical for me is a lot of it deals a
lot with technology but that's not the
the driving force or inspiration for me
it's like I am interested in what it's
like to be a person right now and being
a person right now involves a lot of
kind of new developing technologies but
I think some of the questions that I'm
interested in are things that people
have been wondering about for years and
will probably continue to wonder about
yeah okay you touched on this a few
times with a couple pieces but moving
from terrifying means terrifying us from
the idea of like giving these like
individualistic the power to
to perceive my relationship more
effectively or to or to figure out how
to tax - you know what shifts when all
of a sudden like we are all enabled with
this maybe maybe not that it's just two
people who the same technology but
something that's actually jointly trying
to coordinate our activities together to
make us more effective so for example
that the point day we basically had
completely separate
crowds talking to each other or maybe
not but I'm wondering you know if the
entire point of me of the orchestra was
to get to people in New York to like to
get together without knowing each other
without knowing it or anywhere that are
happening I'm just curious like could we
could we do that or is that like is that
beyond what you think what we might be
able to help these kinds of approaches I
think it's definitely possible when you
see things like whatever a guy
retrieving his cell phone from China or
whatever I don't like we obviously have
this potential to kind of network and
make things happen and it's really
that's really an interesting direction
for me so I think with all this work I'm
kind of expanding as you're pointing out
starting with like something just around
me and then I would like to just keep
seeing like larger and larger scale
interventions and right now that's kind
of at the point of like okay there's an
app that everyone can download but it's
up to every individual to download it
and have their own experience and I'd
love to see what happens if there's like
a larger kind of mass coordination yeah
yeah you can basically change it really
all right well no we don't care about
pleasantries anymore yeah and like the
app is basically amazing this yeah
poking me or whatever really it's sort
of like again some of those old studies
where they would go to the kids summer
camps and like little summer camp
experiments we all walked into this
really fun yeah I mean it's like the
Facebook being gun so we've seen that
they you know they found they could
actually manipulate a political election
but you know what if it's
like something kind of arising from a
group of people that decides they want a
change rather yeah top-down corporation
deciding yeah super interesting yeah so
a lot of your work seems to have the
premise that you know some relationships
need assistance and you know a lot of
help is required to manage social
relationships but some could argue that
you know it's a process that humans just
have to go through some of this in order
to build themselves both character and
so forth
so how do you determine which project is
worth pursuing is worth you know helping
folks out there yeah well I mean I don't
think any of any of these projects I've
made I necessarily want to see become
the norm you know so I make this people
keeper thing and there is an optimistic
angle to it but I think as it is it
disturbs me also and I would hope that
we don't all need to use this out
although the question is like what if it
is what if it helps what if it does work
so yeah in terms of like I know if a
good technology is gonna solve a social
problem like this really what I hope is
that it can just make us reflect a
little bit and so maybe it's almost like
an excuse or a mechanism to see things
differently
and in terms of choosing projects I
think it's really personal so you know
I'm usually kind of going with this
little pretense that I'm trying to like
hack a solution to some thing I don't an
issue I have but really it's more like
there's something I want to understand
better and by trying to approach it from
a different angle that gives me some
kind of different understanding or
relationship with with it yeah it seems
like maybe it's not though okay so that
you don't spend as much time thinking
about Billy Rose these prototypes evil
which is great because you get all these
interesting things but definitely some
of them make you part of the cut a lot
and a huge amount of anxiety around it
it's just how it actually gets
integrated into social fabric so I was
just wondering is have you thought about
that stuff that you just didn't talk
about it as much
yeah I think I think my work is not
directly trying to address that and at
least not in terms of like a interaction
design perspective for a particular app
you know I'm more interested in these
larger questions of like why do we feel
it's okay to sit back and watch
harassment happen or why do we not have
an app that or why do we not like
support people feeling different in some
way or why do we have this kind of
expectation
so it's a little more of an approach
like that but absolutely all these apps
have some varying amount of potential
for misuse or abuse and that was a big
question with the interact one when that
when I first made that you were saying
well what if it's gonna be you know and
we had to do a lot in the there are some
scenes like the guy and girl rolling
down the hill where we had to do a lot
of editing so that didn't just look like
weird and not creepy and messed up so
yeah I think you kind of nailed it like
it's there there's that failure mode but
there's also the kind of like larger
built-in failure that I expect all these
apps have in some way because of the
kind of ambiguous place I'm trying to
position it between earnest and critical
that that particular failure is not the
first one that's going to come up with
the things that I'm making and they come
off hugely in other systems and we're
starting to see people kind of push back
like for example at Twitter and dealing
with online abuse and stuff and you know
that all that's really interesting to me
there so a lot of your work seems to me
to be really reflective and like you
talked about sort of walking out lying
between the awareness and beings are
critical about things that exist in the
world already and it's sort of a curse
to me that some of the things you've
made are not that much more absurd than
sort of mainstream things and I guess
like one thing I've been thinking about
lately is that periscope you see now
that I've already have some of that it
like voyeurism stuff you were doing with
that so I guess I'm wondering what if
you've thought about specific aspects I
your work that like makes it
specifically reflective
yeah well I think one thing that I'm
trying to do is or one way I think about
sometimes is trying to like jump five
years into the future or maybe even just
like three or one but if you think about
like what for example Facebook is now
compared to what it started with I think
if we had just jumped here you know ten
years ago or five years ago we would
people would kind of freak out
but because they kind of roll it out
very step-by-step it's never enough to
make us say like I'm out of here or this
I don't want this or we sometimes don't
even see it happening and so one thing
I'm trying to do is make this jump and
make it now like yeah we might have
people keeper in a couple years and it
would no one will care but maybe by
seeing it now and feeling this kind of
discomfort in reaction to it it might
start us talking about it and
potentially like steer in a direction
that's that's different so it's hope
it's trying to get a little reaction to
what the future could be into like
reflects on what what that might be and
whether we want it
yeah so crowdsourcing the post sometimes
there's a two very different reactions
one is oh my gosh yes I would love to be
able to tap into sort of contributed its
social intelligence of humanity
sometimes there are very humanely
negative reactions about whether other
people are actually smarter than I am
like so many people have relationship
troubles so many people like I I was the
odd one in high school and I only
succeeded by being the odd one and
everyone who was the average person is
now you know in that small town where I
grew up and never escaped and there's
really vehement like reactions to this
this can never be but they never read
any of the feedback you've gotten has
had that kind of character to it and if
so what your reaction is to it because I
felt like you sort of started out the
talk in the position of well I clearly
can't be any worse off than I already in
yeah
but it seems to me like maybe it seems
like some people have don't hold that
position and it's it's been an
interesting journey for native centers
it's kind of like um I think I read
something that said like you know if you
ask someone just objectively like who's
a better driver you or someone else and
they might read the other person higher
but then he say like who would you feel
more comfortable driving this car like
people are disproportionately say
themselves which it you think about
logically doesn't make sense um yeah I
don't I mean maybe that's the reason
part of the reason some people don't
want to use this app it was one like
these apps um it was one that was
actually kind of related to a reporter
was asking me like what do you think
about this fact that like Ben seems so
much more upset about Cobb had been
women and I said yeah I don't I don't
have a hypothesis and his was that women
are men are less likely that it felt to
him the app was like holding up a mirror
I like asking other people what they
thought and he said as a man he didn't
feel comfortable doing that that he felt
like it wasn't their business or that
they might like you know that wasn't
something that women do so I do much
more often right they like kind of ask
their friends for advice generally um
yeah I don't know if I have more
thoughts I actually haven't really
that's so interesting that you said that
because I haven't heard that as much at
least not any actually do this but it
makes sense
maybe I just hang out with more like
average people we're all like yeah we
could take whatever help we get here I
like it in Brooklyn's I would give me an
apartment maybe
let's go bang out a little bit so
they're just kidding about this sort of
work I'm relating this to experience on
t-84 microstructure a static class and
we have the students do a user-centered
design process and they make apps and
some of the ideas that they come up with
seem not entirely dissimilar for some of
the things that yep here but the process
you're going through seems far more
interested in the artistic exploration
and I don't know if you spent any time
doing user centered design or if you
have any thoughts or reflections on how
those processes differ or lead to
different results
yeah I would say because a lot of the
students that I teach is similar things
I think it's sort of like I'm almost
doing this kind of performance art of
being a app developer or a startup
person or a user experience designer so
it's like I'm taking up the role or the
guise of one of these people and trying
to do it convincingly well and so then
there's always the question of like okay
so we have PC funders that now want to
make this app real what do we do
and yeah I mean I guess for me the by
grounding it in what I the personal
questions that I have kind of guides me
and so that that helps me understand
what you know should this go to market
or should this just be another
experiment and going to the next thing
but yeah the process is really similar
and I I've learned a lot from from that
I think one of my first Jobs was like
working in a design consultancy and like
learning that the process of like
breaking down archetypes and so that's
like a really interesting one in the
same way that like using software
metaphors standard that standings I kind
of like use appropriate these different
patterns of working and see what happens
when you make art out of them new
thoughts yeah how do you how do you find
this projects like how are you able to
do that do you like logistically or
financially or personally like
financially like oh yeah very very but
usually and I think someone was just
putting out this is maybe not so
difficult but usually a lot of times
they're self initiated there's not
necessarily like funding from the
beginning I think sometimes it's hard
it's hard to describe this thing and
convince someone that like it should get
made in terms of like a commission or a
grant but then after I start so I'll
just start doing it and then people kind
of get interested so for example at the
social turkish project I just I kind of
set up a residency for myself I like
asked for a month sabbatical off work
and moved to some city where I didn't
know anyone and just like lived in a
hostel and did this project and then
while I was out there I ran into someone
from Intel and they were really
interested in that kind of like human
interaction aspect social computing
aspect of this and so they we sort of
you know they
they ended up like retro actively
funding that project and funding the
development of the cod pilot app so I
don't know if I would necessarily
recommend this is a strategy especially
if you're short on cash but I mean not
that I have a lot and so luckily that's
one reason I do so much stuff that's
very like software and performance based
because you don't have to buy materials
you can just so it's like you know in my
free time coding and working on this and
then hopefully the the passion or the
interestingness of the idea or something
like resonates with someone else and
then they might invite me for a
residency to keep working on it or fund
it in some way
you